[Music]
Apple is claiming that samsung copied
iPhone technology to market its own
products while Samsung's vice president
of electronics has already released a
video that's defending his company it's
a video message defending Samsung let's
take a look
hello Apple's claim that Samsung has
copied their technology as an allegation
were vigorously denying since we entered
the personal electronic space Samsung
has created products that as you can see
bear no similarities happens notice the
gray edge of our galaxy phone and what
about our galaxy tablets not even close
it's not just electronics Samsung's
originality is also on display in our
home appliances whether it's our new
macro wave oven our vac Pro vacuum
cleaner or eye washer would spur
all-wheel control
believe me that come to our retail
stores where you can talk more about our
products with a Samsung smart gun and
you know a lot of people ask how does
Samsung stay so original so innovative
it's very simple really we stay true to
the vision of Samsung founders to farm
jobs
[Applause]